can we actually jump to the
to the at the Horizon as you mentioned
uh as a Social Democrat League you focus
on the policies of today but you also
have a vision and dream of a future and
so Marx did as well so the perfect
communism at the end can you can you
describe that world also is there
elements to that world that's
that has elements of anarchism so again
like I said there's Michael malice next
door so uh like a narco communism I
don't even know if I'm using that term
correctly but basically no central
control can you describe what that world
looks like yeah I think the traditional
socialist vision of kind of if you want
to call it full communism would be very
similar to the anarchist
um vision of a world without uh coercion
Mass abundance and so on I myself don't
share that Vision
um
I believe that we will always need to
have a state in some form as a way to
one um
even just mediate difference I think
traditionally a lot of marxists have
thought that after you remove the
primary contradiction quote unquote of
class
that the other all other political
questions would be resolved and I think
that's a lot behind a lot of the
thinking of we're going to have a full
communism after politics
I don't think there will be an after
politics I think for one thing let's say
I'll give you another Northeast example
let's say me and you were trying to with
different groups of people we're trying
to figure out how to build a crossing of
the Hudson River and for various reasons
you and the people around you want to
build a bridge me and the people around
me need uh want to build a tunnel
that's a question that you will probably
need a mediation for right you'll need
one it's a big project so there'll be a
very complex division of labor and so on
but even beyond that just politically
um you will need the state to mediate
the difference you'll need to have a
vote have a vote that people trust have
institutions of people trust
um and and so on to make a decision
Society is never going to go beyond that
decision making you don't think it's
possible outside of the state to create
stable voting mechanisms
or as human nature can always seep into
that
I just wonder why we would have to if
the state is democratic and responsive
the state is an authoritarian
so it might not be called a state but it
would function as a state right but why
not just call it a state but in other
words like if you don't have something
like that then don't you have a greater
risk of tyranny or Tyrant emerging in
the vacuum so I think people's fear of
this state is what would happen if the
state had too much power and I think
that's legitimate Fair that's why we
have Democratic kind of checks on state
power and and certain guarantees and of
freedom and so on
but
yeah I guess I just wonder I'm more
afraid of the vacuum and not having a
democratic response of state and and
what the world would turn into and also
I'm just not a utopian thinker if that
makes sense like I've I like to think
that Dominique egalitarian thinker I'm a
socialist but
my mind just goes to like you know I
could see a vision of the future that I
would like like 50 60 years from now
um maybe there's some sort of future of
super abundance and Automation and
there's some sort of techno utopian
future we don't want some of those
things that that would exist in my
um you know five minutes from now vision
of socialism but I just don't see it and
in general I'm kind of wary of visions
of change that seem like they're not
built off little thing pieces that we
have now and not built off history and
experience and whatever else like I
don't want a year or zero I don't even
like the term prehistory because I think
there's a lot
in history that I want you know I want
Shakespeare under socialism you know I
want I want a lot of things that that I
think we should be grateful for
um there's a part of tradition that I
think that exists that's hierarchical
and exploitative and whatever else but
there's another part of tradition that's
our sense of place and belonging and our
connection with the past and hopefully
the the future and I I want to keep that
yeah so you're worried about Revolution
or otherwise the vacuum being created
and you're worried about the
the things that might fill that vacuum
so the anarchists often worry
about the
the same mechanism of the state that
controls voting
or keeps voting robust and resilient and
stable the same mechanism also having a
monopoly on violence
and so that's the tension so they're
very they get very nervous about a
central place having a monopoly on
violence whereas if there is going to be
a place within a monopoly on violence
let's just say we temporarily take that
for granted
should it not be a place with a skilled
elected accountable transparent civil
service with a democratic mandate and so
on